as the end to the cdc moratorium nears a
lot of people facing eviction here in
nevada
the state announced today there's now an
option to keep people in their homes and
help landlords get the money they need
sasha loftis joining us in the newsroom
to break down assemblyville 486
and also some of the options it offers
sasha denise governor sysolak and local
leaders say
their goal here is to keep people in
their homes as the cdc eviction
moratorium ends later this week
they also want to provide landlords with
assistance to pay their bills
assembly bill 486 which was signed into
law earlier this year prevents a tenant
from being evicted
if they have proof they filed a rental
assistance application
the court will then place a hold on the
case and arrangements will be made for
the landlord
until the rental assistance goes through
eligible landlords who own single family
homes can also apply for assistance
through this program
governor sissellac spoke on the
importance of it for everyone
as the pandemic has changed and evolved
so has our approach to the moratorium
and we've been able to build out rental
assistance programs
with state and county partners mediation
programs with the court system
and most recently by partnering with the
nevada legislature
to create a so-called glide path for
evictions
it is important to note in order to
qualify for this you have to have that
application for rental assistance
already in so leaders recommend applying
now before the moratorium
expires now i did ask about support for
those unable to keep up with rising rent
here in nevada
though this particular legislation won't
help with that clark county is working
on a specific support program if you
want to learn more about ab486 or apply
we have information
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting in
the newsroom tonight sasha loftis
8 news now